[音楽]
俺の名前は野炭治郎。鬼になって妹を人間に戻す双方を探してる。
石を語らできる修行だ。ここから山の麓まで降りてこい。
[拍手]
[音楽]
大点別だ。行ってこい。
お、
ここまでよく頑張った。これがお前の刀だ。あれ?腐っちゃった。おかしい。
[音楽]
実は俺サイコバスなんだ。
善逸ちょっと鼻よ。
伊之助、もっと早く走れないか。や、や逸
と伊之助は本当にいいやつだな。
あんなとあんなんとなんなんとあんな無限列車の被害拡大中たちに西へ向かえ
だる
うまいうまいうまいうまい拝見たします拝見たします
[音楽]
切プ
600円か。
俺たちは仕事で来てるから払わなくていいよな。
1分背景
買ったんですけど落としちゃいました。へこってるな。どうしたのかな?あ
[音楽]
あ。
だからないって
背いたします。
ないって
相ない。
はい。ないないないないないな。
こいつは無人列車をしたことでキープに採掘してやる俺の結術から逃れた。
脳みそが頭に詰まってないのか。
お前はもう黙れ。切符のことを話すな。
これは想定外だ。
お眠り。
誰だお前?
こいつ目が濁りすぎて術が効かない。
日の神楽なのせ。
負けるのか死ぬのかな。
だこや
いててててててて。
お前も鬼にならないか?
[音楽]
ならない。
死ぬ。死んでしまうぞ。次郎。
う、腕が抜けぬ。う、じあ、
今だ。田少正少年。こいつの首を切れ。
煉獄さんになんて言われようと。
か少年。
逃げるな。逃げるな。卑怯者。
俺はお前から逃げてるんじゃない。社掌から逃げてるんだ。
見いたします。
お前なんかより教の方がずっとすごいんだ。柱ならば後輩の盾になるのは当然だ。俺は弱者が大嫌いだ。
うめ。辛い。
[音楽]
お腹が減ったんだな。お兄ちゃん、街で攻めようってお金を稼えてくるから待ってておくれ。
大丈夫だ。禰豆子。
家族がいない。今はお兄ちゃんがい家の稼ぎ柱だからな。すぐ戻ってくるからな。
ああ、
段が遅い。
遅い。
が遅い。
くそ金がなくなった。が遅い。
[拍手]
失われたお金は回避しない。2
度と戻らないなら奪うしかない。金の呼吸つの方逃げだ。
[音楽]
夕郭行くぞ。うまいうまいうまいうまいうまい。
さあ、始めようか。宴の時間だ。
不合そうネクラ女。なんでお前は喋らない
んだ?
それは無視の呼吸ってやつか?
聞いてんのか?バカなを。
水の呼吸の方
切りけ。
[音楽]
さようなら。
喋ってくれた。
指示されてないことはコインを投げて決める。今あなたを殺すか殺さないかを決めた。殺すが表、殺さないが裏だった。
表が出たから殺す。
さよなら。
おお。よや、よや、よや、よや。
おお。
仲良くするのは無理なようですね。
心を燃やせ。展開を超えろ。あ。あ、
もしもし。大丈夫ですか?
た、太陽忘れてた。レ子全集中。
レッツゴー。おはよ。
あちゃ
[音楽]
[拍手]
すいません。
青白い顔しやがってよ。今すぐ死んじまいそうだな。
私の顔色は悪く見えるか?
とても。私の顔は青白いか?白いというかキモい。弱に見えるか?もう病気だろ。長く生きられないように見えるか?死にそうに見えるか?クじく。太陽さえ克服すれば私は永遠を手に入れることができる。
それならいい薬があるよ。この薬を使えば人間に戻って太陽を克服することができる。
[音楽]
さあ、怖がらずにこっちにおいで。ああ、温かい。これが陽光。
よ、よ。
俺たち友達
[音楽]
無ザー。親方様の元に
2人で謝りに行こう。
いいのかど炭治郎。
俺たちの友情は永遠だ。
[音楽]
[拍手]
初めましてだね。鬼物さん。私は親速反省している。う屋敷
天ね。これは悪夢か。
紛れもない現実です。
親方様、無惨は人間になり、心から反省しているようです。
へへ。お、
何を釣る?死後の世界で永遠になろう。親方様妻以内に無算と来ます。親方様をお取りにして無惨の首を取ります。
他の子供たちは私を取りに使うことを承知しないだろう。
いいえ、満上一承知してました。
う、う、
このボタンを押して屋敷ご爆発してください。
早く押せ。あんたは重要じゃない。
あんたが死ねば殺さの式も上がる。私は
い。
おりゃー。はあ。
貴様がこれから行くのは地獄だ。
地獄に行くのはお前だ。
不りな鬼りでもこ宵い皆殺しにしてやろう。
[音楽]
次回
さあ始めようか。
ついに始まったとの最終決戦。
サイコバスな俺炭治郎は全てをかみだった
んとも
全員を倒して混沌とした世界を実現できるのか。
もしも炭治郎がサイコバスだったら
2、11月7日金曜日開定。
見ないとお前の家に行って。